I think we can do this
Daisy I've been thinking and you know
thinking it is it's in
they ask you where you going just tell
them where it is
you've been Monday through Friday
our shelving days as one must be sly try
steal my morning from these agents uh
sue me
amen that's it I said right there that's
it I try to steal my mornings from these
agents of misery that's what he said
right there and that's uh that's Kohli
Garrett herger at colega repped and that
song is called ode to Daisy and I have
the link to that to that SoundCloud of
the song and the in the information
below the podcast hello thank you guys
for being here kind of a different you
know I you know it's Thursday so happy
Thursday to you and yeah it just slipped
over into the studio you know I got some
chairs coming I was gonna try to have a
guest today and couldn't get it couldn't
couldn't get chairs in time to be lined
up and ordered some chairs and they got
two chairs coming and so you know it's
nice when you have them chairs coming
you know when you got because if you
have a chair eventually you have a place
to put somebody because that's the thing
if you're just standing around with
somebody that's at a certain point that
[ __ ] will get awkward but boy you got
that chair you say hey let me uh let me
introduce you ass to a little bit of
peace right here and then you sit their
ass down into a chair and that's crazy
think about that somebody even invented
a chair think about that like a long
time ago everybody was just standing
around people just standing around like
now what and then finally you know some
straight up I'm gonna be honest hero
came along and said tada
and everybody was I mean that must have
been like it must have been like a like
marijuana almost at first just putting
your bud and you're letting your thighs
onto a just a place to rest them oh can
you imagine
can you imagine that you've been
standing up for years you've been
standing up for years your family your
father's been standing up your
grandfather has great posture
everybody got spa stir because they've
been standing like a [ __ ] and
then suddenly out of nowhere some some
beautiful little carpenter some dirty
little wood martyr comes along and just
chisels out a damn seat and you set that
ass into a chair for the first time mmm
I mean I bet semen just leaks out of
your pores can you imagine how good that
feels just that full body [ __ ] you know
just coming out of your hole just out of
your pores just or just a man imagine
seeing and watching your grandfather sit
down for the first time just till the
tears that would come out of his eyes
after being a lie you know because then
those in the old old old days I'm
talking you know back when people
probably did barely just had necklaces
and stuff like that people barely had
even a lot of ideas just a lot of
necklaces and just you know a lot of
undercooked meat in those days and so
everybody's been standing and then
somebody comes along and makes a chair
you even fathom that feeling that first
seat just take a sit bro just take a sit
huh and watching your grandfather who's
been standing up his whole life which at
that time was probably you know senior
citizens were 40 years old back then you
know if you weren't like about 45 you
were gonna die of the elements her
yellow fever
you know lightning lightning killed way
more people back in because we didn't
have houses think about that like right
now yeah there's lightning out there you
don't even know it
back in the old days there was lightning
okay if the lords were shooting straight
up fireworks at your scalp you knew it
but imagine your grandfather you know 40
year old grandfather because yeah by 45
he was gonna be dead a fever or wolves
wolves I mean in the old days think
about how many wolves probably got 25%
of the population wolves but imagine him
does he's been alive for 39 years you
know and he gets to sit down for that
first time in a chair and just and
that's beautiful
and that's beautiful I don't know I'm
talking about that I forgot why we even
got him on that tangent but thank you
guys for being here with me today oh I
just came in here and I just sat down
and you know and it's Thursday night and
it's uh I mean it's Thursday and it's
you know we want to give that hitter to
you you know we want to give that hitter
and speaking of hitters we got great
block pizza and you know great block
pizza is out here in Los Angeles at 1811
Pico Boulevard on the way to the beach
you're gonna get some sunshine you know
what goes good with UV rays gang gang
that hitter so fill your gullet with
that Italian bullet baby shoot yourself
in the throat with some great block
pizza oh what's up man
you know I start like I got the episode
from last off from Monday's episode on
my mind honestly and on my heart a
little bit they had that you know the
young fella from London called up and I
got a ton of responses about it you know
a lot of people could just feel that cat
you know just feel that little British
kit and they could feel him leakin a
little they could feel his emotion you
know when you hit when you when you find
some emotion it's just it's a it's it's
it's amazing that even through just
airwaves through I mean first of all he
hit the hotline he come from Britain
United Kingdom over there where who
knows what they're doing you know
they're still fighting all kinds of
diseases and everything rats the plague
all kinds of [ __ ] they have a queen
these are people that still have a queen
and he calls up here
you know cuz he has struggles and he has
you know he's feeling discomfort you
know and he's feeling uneasy inside of
himself and he hits that hotline and
that call comes across the the the
universe that call comes across the
universe like somebody just took a
handful of words and feelings and
bunched him into a ball and threw him as
hard as they cut across the Atlantic and
then they landed right here in the
studio and then we blasted him back out
we blasted we turned in that double play
you feel me we blasted that thing back
out and we got a lot of responses and so
we're gonna you know ya just had a lot
of responses I'll get to some of those
you know those calls that came in for
that young man
and and this is a follow-up episode so
I'm gonna get right into the follow-up
you know I mean y-you know what what am
I gonna move it around for what am I
gonna do it later always I'm like I'm do
this later I'm gonna do this I'm gonna
do this [ __ ] right now you know we got
some things to talk about on here today
I mean I got a brain full of all types
of things you know I can't stop thinking
about you know I've been seeing a
therapist and I don't know if I want to
go anymore you know and then and it's
risky because it's like you know I know
that I'm not well but I also know that
you know I have a couple weeks in there
where it's like I just don't know if I
have a lot to talk about and then and
then suddenly I get the idea that a lot
I don't need this anymore so you know
that's kind of something that's
impressing in my brain you know cuz you
shelling out that loot every time you
know I'm shelling out 150 US to go see
this little brain baby to go see this
you know uh adult therapist and I
respect her you know and it's just you
know you start but put that part of your
brain that's probably not even the well
part they're probably the unhealthy part
of my brain start saying man you don't
need to [ __ ] man you don't need any [ __ ]
you know let's get back out there you
know let's sell cabbages you know let's
get some bloke a so it's tough man it's
a tough dribble it's a tough dribble
what else I'll fill you in what else
been going
with me you know I had a I had um you
know how to lay D have been spending
time with and you know I've been
realizing for me that it's hard to it's
hard for me to you know I started having
like some thoughts like man well you
know this girl's really special you know
and maybe I can see like some type of a
future and it's just hard for me to even
share that and say it like to verbalize
it you know like I could feel that I can
you know kind of know it I think some
places in my body but to actually say it
you know just like some of the first
time I've ever had some of that stuff
where it's like man I you know I I
really care you know I care and I want
you know I want to say like you know
part of me wants to you know say those
things I'm like say look you know I see
us maybe you know what if we had a
little bit of a [ __ ] yard you know
that's how I'd say you know I'll Drive
it like what if we had of you know what
if we you know use the same blender you
know I get scared to share you know I
think the facts that somewhere inside of
me I'd love to maybe even have a family
and have a you know have a you know an
animal a couple you know uh you know non
livestock but you know a couple G pigs
maybe a couple of you know dogs and cats
outdoor animals probably because I don't
know if I'm competing in the house man I
don't want to wake up in the middle of
the night and see two dogs [ __ ] out
in my hallway I'm not doing that man I'm
not running you know some kind of a pet
brothel I want to I want you know but
you know but it's like never in my life
have I thought I would want those things
you know I thought all that shot thought
man that's gay you know I thought that
that's lame you know oh you got a yo you
got a family van
that I hope y'all get shot up by some
bangers you know I used to think all of
that I think a lot of that stuff was
probably uh you know just came from the
fact that I didn't since I didn't have
it growing up I didn't have any respect
for it you know since I didn't have any
since I didn't have it growing up I
didn't have any respect for it Oh your
parents have a happy marriage man [ __ ]
them you know oh you're uh you know you
know you got y'all just moved into a new
house man [ __ ] that yella sellouts you
know always had all of that [ __ ] if I
didn't have it then [ __ ] you because you
had her [ __ ] it you know and just you
know and then they just be you know now
I'm like thinking about really you know
sharing some of these things just saying
you know the most I could even get
myself to say with like you know what if
you know what if we owned a you know a
cat together you know or what kind of
silverware do you like you know just
things like that where I'm like wow you
know it's just hard to imagine that it's
hard for me to really you know what it
is even beyond it being hard relative
it's hard to realize that maybe part of
me really wants that and to honor that
part instead of just always honoring a
the part of me that just wants to say no
to that if that makes any sense you know
to sit there and and just tell a person
you care about you know like gloves off
you know to take the gloves off your
heart and take those brass knuckles off
your ie orders and just say look you
know I care you know I care you know I
care about you there's some inside of us
if that wants to get out and do that and
inside of me I feel you known as such a
for that beast inside of me is so
foreign to me that it's hard for me to
when those desires come along
almost reject them you know the I it
almost feels like a foreign antibiotic
it feels like a something that shouldn't
be in my system so it's like I got to
fight through those uncomfortable
moments and instead of being hard
sometimes I gotta be I got a soften up I
got to get soft sometimes get soft you
know not in the [ __ ] but in the rest of
my body you know in my heart my you know
maybe in my chest and stuff my chest
gets kind of hard a lot but uh but yeah
so that's wild you notice to know that
some of those things exist inside of me
you know how to know that like and also
I think you know I just have a fear I
have a fear that you know that I might
you know that being in a real you know a
marriage or that any of that kind of
[ __ ] down the road I would be you know I
would uh you know I would cheat or I
would lie or I would mess it up you know
I have I have a lot of fear around that
and some of that is you know it's just
as so much you know I'm sometimes I
don't know if I'm stronger than like all
the influences that are out there
sometimes there's so much influence now
you know you got titties you're on the
bus you might be on the bus and they
trying to sell you cancer drugs they got
a poster for cancer but then they got
this girl there she's like on the
picture of the poster it's like I got
cancer and she's got big old titties you
know like what the [ __ ] why are they
pushing these titties at me you know
they're trying to they trying to keep me
on that chemotherapy via tits and so
it's just there's a lot of just levels
to what's gone stantly bombarded with
that cat with that process
you know with sex it's like sex sex sex
it's like oh you want these you you want
these new beautiful wha you you want
these this new kitchen we're set we'll
look at this [ __ ] you know like oh ah
it just never ends man it's just
constant bombardment with they use the
sex to sell everything and and it's just
you know I don't see how women feel like
they can even compete with that
you know they're like how a woman can
feel sexy when she can't even compete
with the [ __ ] advertisement for a
damn dish where you know where a pleura
silverware said you know you want these
spoons get this ass you're like what
it's just you know and sometimes I just
wonder if I can you know how much that
you know will always be a you know how
I'm gonna ride I'm gonna ride through
that in my life
but I guess you know you know you just
got a car you just gotta you know you
just have to just try and I think be
honest as you battle it because we're
all everybody's out there battling that
man you know everybody's out there
battling it a lot of them you know
marriages of relationships they said
this should don't work as a lot of fun
do we we're just humans and we're big
they're building these at this
advertising these models you know I mean
these advertising templates and models
that are stronger than us these things
are like transformers with tents and
transformers that do you know but sex
and all that so you get out there and
see like I can't [ __ ] battle this bot
you know I'm just a human I'm just built
for the old time way where you know you
maybe you see a you know a you know a
quarter you know 25 percent of a top of
a tit hanging out of a church blouse
you're like oh I can battle that yeah
you know I can fend that off but the
dark arts the cauldron that is being
just stirred out here in the world can I
battle that you know can I battle that
and I think I think it's it's tough I
know it's tough for a lot of guys out
there I know it is
and then don't feel alone so many of my
friends who are married we talk all the
time and that's what we talk about how
can we it's so hard it's hard to fight
that stuff because you're not just
saying you're not saying it's not it's
not that I don't love the person I'm
with it's not I don't love my spouse
it's not I don't care about my
significant other it's
that I'm not as I don't have the skills
yet or the power yet built into me to
stay out of these gutter traps you know
out there within these traps where they
out there selling [ __ ] you know in
advertising with all this you know
titties and booty artwork and everything
it's it's tough and so some of that may
you know I and I have this pressure that
I feel like it well if I can't you know
be a hundred percent sure that I'm gonna
be you know perfect then I'm afraid to
move forward in in relationships I think
that's probably what keeps me out of
them you know in like an inverse kind of
way I think what keeps me out of some
relationships is is knowing that I might
just not be a strong enough person to
you know fully take care of someone else
I guess that's one of my fears out there
but yeah man anyway a lot of emo stuff
out the gate man let me think of some
more stuff that's a little more you know
less emo if we can get into something
like that you know we had some fun calls
that came in these are some good ones
man I love you know I'm starting to
maybe I like this kind of Thursday this
follow-up episode because this is the
follow-up to that Monday this that
follow-up to that killer on Monday and
we had um this lady called in a couple
weeks ago I was talking about burial in
different ways you could be buried you
know and I think there's only a couple
of ways out there you can do cremation
and they do throw you in that box and a
wooden box you know you know wrap you in
that plywood you know wrap uncle wah
Carl and that plywood and drop him you
know drop - you know in that six
thousand dollar hole over there on the
east of town but this lady she said she
they have another idea right here this
kid this call came in on the hotline
here we go
yo Co this is Rebecca from Palm Desert
regarding cremation and burial thank you
for calling Rebecca I appreciate your
call Rebecca I think that means actually
in Spanish it means the
our like the flower salesman sales
salesperson salesman sales woman onward
there is another option and that other
option you can see on a TED talk from
jae-rim Lee woo Jae rim Lee swung too
low
Baga we too low holy SH folk remember
that remember when that plane was
crashed and that's sad but he haven't
seen that video go ahead get that hitter
right there
onward does it by jae-rim Lee onward she
has a TED talk called the mushroom death
suit and it's a really interesting very
old way with where's the suit is
mushroom spores sewn into the suit and
oh that mushroom death suit now that
sounds [ __ ] tasty as hell to be
honest with you you know I think I could
do a mushroom death suit you know wrap
me enough you know in that in that
butter squash neck brace you know that's
what I would do I think that frickin
that cauliflower body cast put daddy in
net you know that beef jerkey
straitjacket I could ride something like
that you know something more flavorful
you know that uh okay you know in that
guac you know that guacamole
straitjacket put daddy in something
flavorful well they you know where
people would be like oh damn you know
he's going to heaven on with a little
bit of uh you know with a couple side
items wrapped under his arms you know
he's going to you know the damn he's got
a [ __ ] brisket they made him a
brisket helmet you know that's a better
way to be buried you know there's just
so many great ways to this there should
be so many great ways to be buried and
to know that somebody out there is
selling a mushroom jacket you know where
you can get all shroom DUP and show up
out in the universe you know I'm saying
when you show up on reincarnation and
you ball and you got a freaking jacket
full of shrooms everybody's gonna wanna
you know 'party your [ __ ] outerwear
and be your friend let's hear more
it basically eats you and you are put
back into the earth naturally so that
you don't leave in behind and so it
takes away the casket takes away
everything else and you just get
even by mushrooms so how you feel about
that you're eatin mushrooms while you're
alive let the mushrooms eat you when you
die
Wow I'm gonna find that TED talk and I
will post it in the in the info at the
bottom that's yeah that's something ma
that [ __ ] you you know what that's a
great idea what if it like this all the
animals you ate during your life okay if
you had a little bit of chicken you know
if you had a couple of you know a little
bit of are a couple of aardvark
medallions or whatever you know a couple
of you know you had some some pork loins
or whatever little couple of pig [ __ ]
whatever you like whatever you had
during your life now when you die and
you're in that casket all those animals
get to come and eat you
wouldn't that be adventurous because
everybody would just a dude ever
everyone would show up to funerals
you're just sitting there being like 9 I
wonder what he ate next you know they
got like a couple of horses roll up they
got a zebra you're like damn Cheryl had
been eatin zebra that [ __ ] had some
tasty snacks you know all you got a
[ __ ] giraffe comes in there and just
puts his long tongue up in yes you could
could you even fathom that what what if
that's how we did it where that funeral
that was that payback you know not only
do people come to pay back their love
and their their the you know to Rhea
moat whatever you had a motive to them
while you guys were alive you know now
today not only get people come to thank
you for the sensations that you had
given them you know and those just heart
vibes as [ __ ] you know just just them
straight-up beautiful Care Bear energy
critters that you would just you know
just put into their soul not only they
come to thank you for those but that
they also but that animals that you had
eaten also got to they got their strike
back you know Matt can you imagine all
the cattle that would show up all the
steaks a lot of us have probably had all
the cattle shows up and they come and
get that that snack they come like ah
this [ __ ] you have my ribs [ __ ] I'm
but I have you yo ribs
and a cow just rolls off with a [ __ ]
half a rack you know and no dipping
sauces gang that'd be beautiful but I
see I see what you're saying there and I
appreciate you telling me about that
they got that mushroom jacket so if you
ate shroom shroom Zeit you cool and then
if they gave those shrooms out like ten
years later they find those spores and
grow them out and give them to everybody
that was at the funeral and everybody
can take a mushroom and know what you've
been going through everybody can get
that hitter out of you two we're onto
something I love this idea I'm gonna
find that TED talk and I'm gonna put it
in the space there so you could see but
that's a V you know I'm saying that's
that vegan jumpsuit that mushroom
straitjacket that's that vegan jumpsuit
right there and that's what they're
putting in you know that's what they're
putting you in you know just in a [ __ ]
karat coat with some some radish
ray-bans daddy's going to heaven I like
it thank you for that call I appreciate
that thank you for that call we got
another man this story that came in
we're gonna get to some of the responses
you guys had four responses for the guy
in London we're gonna get to those in
just just a minute I want to let you
know I got a couple of new dates coming
on the books I'm gonna let you know
about them right now this April 6th and
7th I'll be in Tampa Florida and that's
at Rock Brothers brewing in the Attic
April 20th through the 21st or will be
in hack Houghton Heights New Jersey at
bananas comedy club
I will also be at Cherokee Casino that's
going to be June 9th out there in
Oklahoma I'll be in Calgary June 15th
and 16th in Canada and then I will be at
good night's comedy club in Raleigh
North Carolina
July 20th and 21st those tickets are all
going to be available this week of via
Theo van comm slash tour t oh you are so
if you can get a peep attack get a peep
it at as well if you haven't seen I had
that this is not happening
launched out there so you guys can go
check that out
I'm gonna put up a version of it at some
point that is the full version my
version you know that's not edited out
there by these companies and stuff like
that so we'll see about that and uh what
else what else we got what else we got
everybody still fight yeah you know all
these news stations still fighting you
know that's just crazy that [ __ ] is
crazy
you know I don't see how anybody could
how can how could I lose stations like
here's the thing everybody talked about
how horrible everybody's life is and
everything since Trump got elected
everybody I know his life is exactly the
same in fact most of my black friends or
Latino friends are getting more work
than ever and maybe it's different in
different places you know maybe I'm not
catching the vibe overall you know but
it's like damn it's like some of this
hate sometimes I'm like when a what the
only most of the hate I see comes off
with the news and [ __ ] this is that's
the most hateful stuff you could see you
know I miss the old news where they just
were like hey somebody won the raffle
and you were like damn Larry won the
raffle damn Hector won the raffle and
that was it and they gave you that
weather and they gave you that Sport
score and you were back to spending time
with your family there wasn't all these
fear tactics out there all this fear and
[ __ ] just I'm just tired man I'm
tired I'm tired of Hollywood just
telling everybody how to live their life
and how wrong we are oh you're not doing
this you're not doing that don't you
know this don't you know that don't you
know we don't [ __ ] know each other do
you know that Hollywood we don't [ __ ]
know each other in fact you don't know
me so much that you don't even know how
to make entertainment for me anymore
that's why your Academy Awards were down
about 20% because nobody [ __ ] cares
anymore cuz you don't care about me you
care about just your way you care about
just that money
but mark my words man money isn't loyal
remember that money isn't loyal you show
up you do your work the rewards will
follow riches will follow it may be
money it may be a wealth of heart it may
be a wealth of knowledge but you some
some type of rich miss will follow do
your work
that's what I'm learning that's what I'm
learning I'm doing my work boy you want
to come at this underdog come at this
underdog
what's that nipping at your nuts
that's this gala so we go on board we
are coming we are coming dude we've got
this call came in right here
this one looks funny it's a funny
teaching his story let's go my name is
Paige and I am a teacher in Seattle
Washington Oh Paige thank you for
calling I was just up in Tacoma last
weekend that's a Coldwater country you
know it's hard to get cold water out
there even in the birdbath you see birds
stop by check the water too [ __ ] cold
take off
diet dehydration you know a lot of water
just too cold for animals even - I
caught a bass it was [ __ ] shivering
you know something you'll catch a bass
or something and they they just flopping
on the counter you know this one [ __ ]
shivering he had water on his body right
and he was bouncing on the wood on the
on the dock and he used the water on his
body just bouncing bouncing bouncing
bouncing bouncing to spell out hot cocoa
he just don't H you know boom boom boom
H uh boom oh and he did all that until
they had no more moisture on his body
hot cocoa I was like Dan you know
everything's cold out here that's cold
water country thank you for calling page
homework oh you wanted to know like
who's watching your podcast and so I do
want to know that and I appreciate it
thank you for calling let's hear more
it's auntie Sarah mill schoolteacher and
I watched your podcast and oh you're a
middle school teacher huh that's amazing
a lot of middle school teachers out
there and that's beautiful man
especially you got a beautiful female
teacher and you a young boy you show up
cuz you sound attractive Paige you know
you sound attractive to me
and all you gotta be is about a four or
up to be attracted to daddy you know so
you sound attractive to me and onward
something funny that happened the other
day and I was thinking about it when you
were talking about like being in middle
school and just like how weird people
are in middle school but I also coached
volleyball and so I mmm and I'm not
supposed to be thinking about I'm not
thinking about that wasn't mmm - middle
school volleyball that was just uh you
know when I think about like a like kind
of an attractive teacher teaching
volleyball that thing kind of wah
you know that thing gets me you know
makes me flare a little you know make my
loins turn in the Lions and that's
really just all you got to do is switch
a letter you know that I'll turn my
loins in a lion's boy yeah I change that
school and so I was changing my
classroom for volleyball okay you change
and let's go back a second here we go
I'm gonna shut up well and so I was
changing my classroom back a little more
here we go cool and just like how weird
people are in middle school but I also
coached volleyball and so I change at
school and so I was changing my
classroom for volleyball mm-hmm man I
don't know if I'm being a pervert or
from just being just regular you know in
Los Angeles you're not allowed to have
any interest in women anymore so you
know I feel like what we're doing right
now is very it's like almost like
prohibition but that I'm secretly having
to do this in a studio somewhere on the
third floor of a building homework and I
just like left all my clothes on like
near my desk and I like changed into a
sports bra and so I like oh man like I
don't you ever have like one of your
fantasies you feel like it just called a
telephone number that's what I feel like
right now I mean this is this is some
you know this is a middle school teacher
telling me she just changed in her
classroom and you got me you know you
got my Weiner starting a loiter around
you know around my waistline you feel me
oh my I take off my rock and I'll go to
hear that part again sorry changing to a
sports bra and so I have to take off my
bra and so my like bra and all my
clothes are like sitting there and then
today but you couldn't see the brothel
the next day the kids came in they said
I knew you lived here I knew you lived
here you have all your clothes here your
the suitcase here and like I have to
keep my suitcase at school cuz it
doesn't fit in my apartment cuz I live
in Seattle and so I was like you know
what and I'm like grabbing my clothes
and I'm putting it in this bag I'm like
- none of your business and outfalls
my bra on to the ground and there was
two eighth-grade boys and one of them
ran for the door they both went and ran
oh he probably went to masturbate I'm
guessing I mean I couldn't imagine that
you know and I'm not trying to you know
and I know you're probably thinking he
went for something else but at eighth
grade if an attractive teacher dropped a
bra in front of me I would be Ludd good
I would probably be I'd be I turn into a
louis c.k boy I'd start Weingarten in
those plants or whatever Harvey
Weinstein er I hit those plants and to
start Weinstein it you know what I'm
saying I put a you know I put a pearl
necklace on a cactus if you had a
[ __ ] cactus in the window homework
and the other boy he was so they're
staring at it and I jumped on it like it
was a grenade covering it up and I was
like Oh God a hot teacher jumping on her
bra in the classroom I mean this is
Paige thank you so much I got to here
I'm gonna hit play this again later in
the car but I want to hear it again
let's hear a little more Thank You Paige
and so they ran out of the classroom but
you know it's tough out here and also
I'm coming to your show with my best
friend Taylor this weekend and in Tacoma
and we're so excited to see you oh I
didn't even realize Paige I thought that
was from this week thank you thank you
for calling ah thank you so much and I
hope you and Taylor had a nice time wow
that's a sexy story though I just heard
this a sexy story you know and shout out
to the kid who stayed around at 8th
grader that's a G right there that boy
sees that bra hit the ground and all the
one dude he's out that dude ain't gonna
get laid until probably late into
college but that eighth grade boy he's
thinking man
No maybe we playing a strip poker
without the cards you know and and miss
page went first
oh man you make me want to go back to
middle school man you make me wish I
couldn't really read and spell that well
you know and you know I just you know I
could do some algebra but barely so that
I could go back to middle school and
just apply myself to some fine teachers
you know thank you for calling page
that's that's a ha that's everything did
I remember I'm trying to think of the
hot I mean first of all I remember as a
kid in middle school so I was attracted
to any teacher you know even if it was
like a male teacher of real long hair
who conditioned his hair if that do
turned around to face the board and he
had a nice ass boy I think about him you
know I mean I had feminine wiles but if
he came across as a as feminine into my
eyes bone then I've just projected right
under my brain because you and all you
had to do was think about something and
your dick would start looking for
somebody remember that you know I never
owned a pet growing up really outside of
you know small ground game but man
having a penis when you're young it's
like having a pet it's like having a you
know it's like having a you know it's
like having a runt feet runt ferret that
has attention deficit disorder you know
your dick I started looking around you
know it's a damn everything it's just yo
dick is just you know your dick Oh eat a
pizza you know your dick you'll you will
eat a corn kernel I bet your dick has so
much you know relativity at that point
when you're young your penis got that
vibe
boy your penis is just show up yep I
mean yeah your penis will provide
services you're reading a book you don't
have a um
book stopper a word remember piece of
paper
BAM your dick shows up I got you though
you know when you're yelling your penis
is violent it's vibrant
you know your penis looking
things to do I bet man I bet there's got
to be a video out there somebody had
taught their penis to eat a piece of
corn and if you have that video send
that in man I'm not gonna you know I'm
not gonna watch it more than one time
you know but I will watch it for you
know the artistic nurse of it and the
you know hash tag vegetarian but yeah
man those you know that was young and I
pretty you know I remember I remember
who died oh man we had this teacher I
think her name was like Miss bout Doan
or miss Boudreaux or somebody I think I
was 7th or 8th grade and she had her few
were like perfume and she had I mean she
just looked like every boy I know can't
do math from my hometown and it's
because of her it's her fault dude I
wanted to get problems wrong so I could
stand there and just smell her while she
like showed me the work she's like you
got to show your work and I'm just like
I can't think cuz mmm 60% of the blood
is in my penis and nuts when I'm sitting
there listening to her you know I could
even bend my legs that's how I wrecked I
was you know I had to roll over to her
desk and then you know pull myself up by
my arms and those were just I mean Miss
Bowden what was her name miss Vaughn
Baum I don't know she just I remember
here's how sexy she was I remember she
wore red that's all I remember
she might have never worn red but I
that's just what I room she but red is
that color of sex of lust it's just like
in my brain she wore red she had dark
hair and like you know all of my
youthful masturbation and probably a lot
of my young erections I you know I you
know I would attribute to her probably
or you know if I could leave something
my will it would be for her you know it
would be for her to get you know maybe
now in her life I don't know if she has
a man now or whatever but you know a lot
of women as they get a little bit older
they still want to catch him you know
you know some routine cop you know some
Hardy and I was young back then but you
know my dick had an old soul I always
felt like that and my dick had had seen
things my dick had seen railroads being
built you know my dick had heard like a
you know like a printing press in the
distance my dick had seen but I had an
old soul at an old soul day and if I
could leave something in a will or
something if I would leave a lot of
those old directions of my past to her
what was her name miss oh it might've
been miss Garofalo I think did she
change your name I don't know she oh she
changed her name one time and then
everybody's like she's divorced you know
so then who I can't even imagine half
the class you know came to school
sluggish or cross-eyed the next day
because when you were young when I was
young if he jerked off too much you went
cross-eyed one of your eyes would get a
little dry because you were expelling a
lot of the moisture out of your body
through your Weiner but what else is
going on dude I got about six days right
now of no masturbation so I'm feeling
good about that you know somebody
struggling out there with those dark
arts hit that hotline nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three you
know you can be alone while you jerk off
but don't feel alone or feel shameful
for doing it
you know it's addictive world out there
you know where you know you do you at
the market you trying to buy some
applesauce and you know the advertising
is you know they're just showing you
somebody's at you know a hot chicks ass
full of apples and you're like wouldn't
you like these get this moths get these
moths six-packs you're like what the
[ __ ] they're making it hard for because
then once you got that you got to go get
them other hitters now you got now you
need mental health now you need the Emir
wrecked-tile tablets and I look I pop
five milliliter cialis out the gate dude
I just got a whole shipment of um some I
think it's from India some Indian
levitra and this [ __ ] got my legs
sweating at night but I'll take it dude
I'll take five Milly's if I'm just
rolling around the the the neighborhood
because I like to feel you know spoke
now I like to feel awake well you got
you if you if you run it on five
Millie's in your weenie do it even the
next day you still got two milligrams
any you know you still got two
milligrams in you I see a dude an old
man walking with a cane and I'm like
same bro
same but what else we got man we're
gonna get let's get to this London
collar in just a second I want to let
you know about Beachbody on demand and a
lot of y'all like T Oh what you talking
about me you trying to sneak a ad in on
us here I'm giving you this ad you know
we still got to do some ads right now
because we don't you know we [ __ ] got
to get stuff in here you know we got to
get things in here I just I just had to
order two chairs off the internet and
them chairs was 170 dollars per chair
per chair so those are coming in you
know but Beachbody on demand its online
Fitness streaming service they got all
those for the famous ones p90x you know
what else they got insanity 21 day fix
t25 three week yoga retreat that's the
one I'm doing because you know I'm
trying to stretch out before I you know
go for that beach fitness so I'm going
for that three-day yoga retreat and
those are Beachbody programs you can
access all of them 24/7 so you wake up
at 4 a.m. you know I'm saying you pay
you take a urine or whatever in your
house and you know you look at your lady
or you if you got a man you look at your
man you know check on the children or
whatever everything's cool
you like [ __ ] I got a lot of extra
energy right now you could watch
Dateline again or you could jump on to
Beachbody on demand they got all kind of
programs it's accessible on your
computer your web TV smartphone whatever
it has programs for any fitness level
everything and you need to give it a try
so right now my listeners can get a free
trial membership when you text tpw 2 3 0
3 0 3 0 so that means text tpw 2 3 0 3 0
3 0
that's the number three zero three zero
three zero texts EPW and you'll get to
access the entire platform I'm gonna try
this yoga let you know how it's going ah
so thank you guys for your patience and
support let's get it uh let's see we got
another call that came in here but I
don't want to talk about yeah we that
cover that came in by Thai nice and who
last week that boneyard it was cool you
know know if I wasn't you know it uh the
audio I think on it was tough for me and
I never heard of boneyard but I'm so
grateful to tiny managed to think that
somebody's out there helping out
somebody's out there to send in
something in a lot of great music has
come in and we're still gonna try to do
that special music episode where we
roast all the music I know I know we're
gonna do it what else let's do this man
let's take let's get into the end of
this London calls right here man let's
get into him this call came in last week
and this was from this young fella in
London and I've had so much response to
it I'm gonna play a little bit of it for
you are right now
alright see I'm eight I'm not sure if
it's obvious from my tone but a little
bit uncomfortable leaving this message
but just sort of want someone to talk to
about this and I know the theory one
past weekend family think there's some
people who can give me some useful
feedback
I guess I've run into a bit of a
crossroads in my life sort of chatting
[ __ ] yeah
I've got a bit of a drug problem and
yeah I don't know my problems but um I
keep on justifying everything with right
self PE and I don't know at what point
do you stop feeling Sophia so it's a
great question you know and I appreciate
that call uh we had a couple calls that
came in that were responses for you and
we had a text as well that came in and
if you missed the end of last week's
episode that's what this was about you
know
we have this young you know we had this
young fella call in 20 years old from
London and and it's got a ton of
response and the interesting thing for
me was the next day I was thinking like
man what can I do you know it offers
some you know to offer to be of service
to try and help out what can I do you
know I don't live in London I don't and
literally I'm thinking about that and
some man just out of the blue I think
his name is Alex Hitchens just sent me
an email and he said yeah I'll read it
right now just out of the blue he said
here he goes dude please pass on the
last caller from your hotline if you
want to you cake a fella to talk to 12
years sober myself from booze and can be
there as a friendly ear who has some
understanding of addiction and
depression if he wants to talk and he
just sent his number out of the blue out
of the blue man and it was literally
like wow it's one of those moments like
I don't know what to do and then BOOM so
you know I reached out to the caller and
offered you know and offer that and we
have some suggestions that came in from
our listeners and I can't control you
know what the caller does it you know
and it's you know and it's not about
that you know it's not about like you
know we're not a professional
organization here you know I can't
control if you know if that young man
feels like he needs help right now you
know or if he gets help right now if he
you know I know I can't I can't make it
anybody's choices you know but I I don't
think there was a man out there when
that boy wasn't talking that you didn't
feel something you know and if I feel
something man and if there's something
there if I'm feeling something there's
something there yeah I know in my it's
not even a choice I make it's just an
it's something inside of me when I feel
something you know we have to take we
have take you know I don't know if it's
some sort of action but I just know that
there's something there and so we had
some couple of calls that came in here
we go
is just doing it from Alden anyways just
for my buddy in London this Dylan from
London I'm sorry about what happened to
your father his sickness in your family
what you said last episode sounded like
something that's really hard to get you
know any any of us would have a hard
time getting through that but when I say
for advice if you really need advice I'm
26 years old so I'm not much older than
you but what I say is um number one is
your health like make sure your health
is all right because that's gonna keep a
strong nation that you eat organic food
make sure you learn how to cook and you
said you were you know you live an
excessively calm comfortable lives maybe
you don't know how to cook but
definitely learn how to cook our
vegetables you know cooking stuff in the
oven it's really simple make it yourself
exercise you get yourself to the gym
because that's gonna have those two
things gonna have so many positive
influences here in your life it's gonna
get your boiling it's got me tell you
confidence it's gonna make you feel a
lot better and when you come out
conscious you're not going to want to do
drugs
Wow and that's a good for this you know
that's it is amazing it's amazing how
when you get that blood flowing that
your blood will do things for you that
you can't do for yourself it's amazing
when we start to stir the good parts of
our body that they will start to inspire
us you know you start you once you go to
the gym you give up from the gym you
don't want to eat that cake now
now you instead you maybe want to have
at least a carrot cake you know that a
little bit of meet them in the middle
you don't want carrots but you don't
want cake broth [ __ ] do them both you
know I might not have pudding but I
might have some [ __ ] you know I might
have a um you know some a couple of
beats you know a couple of red beets and
some arm
pedda force you know or some lady
fingers I might have some brussel
sprouts some leg you know if lady
fingers under them or something you know
I'm saying and so that yeah if you get
that fitness man once you you get your
body stirring dude and let it do the
magic your body will start to do things
that it wants to do that are good for
you
like he's saying you do a couple you
know it's a little bit of fitness a
little bit of veggies you know and now I
know sometimes it's hard to do that if
you actually have some you know if
you're caught on the depths of addiction
the best stuff can be really tough but
thank you Dylan for those for those
suggestions here we go in another call
here we go
HBO it's another one of your
london-based fans here max hey max I
appreciate you :
onward just been watching the most
recent one from the 19 anyway just a
couple of things firstly I wanted to say
yeah you know I'm calling about the guy
called it also from London not just
because we both talk funny I wanted to
say first thing you said near the end
there that you hope that one day this
week or in your life you'll be as brave
as that man for reaching out and I would
just say from my perspective you're
already there man you know it's an
amazing thing you do here and I think
everyone who watches can see there's
more to you than just a joke man you're
the funniest guy on the Internet
there's a real interest in open and
honest side to you that I think really
resonates with people because you're
real man and I think that's really cool
thanks man I appreciate seeing some of
that you know you know day maybe hit me
in a tear ducts for a second dude you
know and we'll get to your suggestion
out it's you know I haven't heard this
call yet so I appreciate you saying that
though you know I think a lot of my life
I just you know I find that I feel the
best when you know sometimes it's the
only place that I really feel good like
I can you know do shows and stuff and
that stuff feels good but I think I feel
the best when uh you know when I feel
just connected to people and somehow in
doing this and you know that London key
you know just something I don't know
when people call in and there's some
real [ __ ] going on I just I don't know
it makes me feel a little bit okay you
know like I feel like we're you know
like we Inc like we're not giving up you
know all of us like we didn't come this
far you know to stay where we are you
know it just I don't know I'm rambling
but thank you man that's what I mean
I just mean thank you that's nice here
to say max homeward anyway wants her
plot II catch the guys name who's having
a bit of a tough time of it now you know
I don't know if I caught it either I
know he texted as well he said that his
father had come down with MS and then
his mother had had a schizophrenic break
and had left them and that's what he was
I know that was things that was going on
in his life and he'd been dealing with
some cocaine use and he as he phrased it
more
days in the month than not and that's
hard man cuz you get on it you know you
do cocaine one night you're out for two
days you know you're out for that next
day that next day is out you're done you
know you're not usually doing it that
next night so unless you start to put up
a real tolerance where you can then go
get that hitter that next night you know
you can gram down you know then that's
probably a tough universe to be in but
let's hear more but yeah that's where he
was from then he and his question was
how you know when I get to self-pity how
do I stop feeling sorry for myself
homeward now but I felt what do you
spend like you did I think and I
emphasize to an extent you know I know
that feeling
much like you said you do and I don't
maybe this is a bit weird but you know
we both this past weekend listeners you
know don't know how many people in
London are maybe you know that but I
just wanted to say you know if you and
if you don't air this you just want to
kind of reach out separately I'd be very
happy to to meet this guy you know
there's things I'm dealing with maybe we
could help each other out somehow you
know be each other's support for trying
to improve our lives get away from these
dark arts get that hit up boy dude
that's awesome man never and I swear
guys I have not heard this call I hadn't
heard this call to hear someone say get
that hitter and British man out you know
might change I might have to change my
feelings about the British man I mean
he'll do it another couple years here in
America there's gonna be a whole
boatload of us going back to Britain you
can get bet that we'll see you on the
shores buddy we are coming back you know
you can't even have any freedoms every
here anymore but you know man I you know
I appreciate that Max and you know what
I will I'll share your information you
know I'll share your information I'm
gonna share your information I'm a share
the gentleman Alex is information who
who who emailed me and thank you you
know it's uh you know I can just hear
your voice man you know you got some
care and you do and I appreciate that
you know cuz this life is [ __ ] hard
bro it's hard for some people and I
think what I can what I could relate to
because you say you could empathize and
what I could relate to when I heard that
kid I could just relate to just hurting
you know I
couldn't really put my yeah I mean I've
hurt you know I've been in pain you know
hi and feeling uncomfortable and not
liking myself and those things but I
could just I could relate to him feeling
not good we can all relate to that
let's you're one more call that came in
for us for some thoughts here here we go
hey deal this is a Julio from New
Hampshire Julio from half town that hamp
town baby ham hell you know saying
happen ain't easy and also we're gonna
launch this new tour the dark arts tour
is coming guys so I'm excited we'll be
adding some more dates on to that Julio
thank you for calling let's hear more
this is a message to that that guy that
left the comment about when do you stop
feeling sorry for yourself or when do
you stop making excuses I think it's all
about when you take accountability for
your for yourself I think that's the big
turnaround for a lot of people I see
them as soon as they they look in the
mirror and they take accountability the
pity stops and everything they stop
feeling sorry
and that's sorry the feeling turns into
a drive because in man I've been I've
been messing up really bad lately
and and I got a really get it together
so taking that accountability is the
first step so hanging there brother I
had a had a brother that lost his life
to drugs and you know he's starting to
make that turn around and unfortunately
went back for one last taste and and
that was it that was the end of it take
accountability be strong and and Bulevar
word man Thank You Julio and I'm sorry
to hear about your brother man you know
I you know my sit like you know one of
my family members winning a treatment
today you know I don't know if I'm
supposed to talk about this kind of
stuff but but you just got me thinking
about it Julio one of my fellows wanting
a treatment today and uh you know it's
hard it's hard when you
when you have you know when there's not
anything that you can do you know you
can love as much as you want you can try
as much as you want you can you can try
to help you can pay for this you can pay
for that you know people you know people
people can't change until they're ready
they can't and there's no there's not a
time that we can do about it but I think
we can offer suggestions you know we're
not telling this young man what to do
how to live his life you know he's young
so that another thing is with you know
sometimes you don't you don't see your
problems when you're that young you
can't see it you know might say he might
be out there who knows you know he might
never need you know he may never need
help I mean do we some of us and maybe
think he does yeah we might we don't
know though but it's nice that there are
people who you know that at least we
care to show up and think about it you
know maybe you were just listening and
you said a prayer form in your heart
maybe thought about him you know I think
I think all of that kind of stuff counts
you know anything that I'm not doing
that's not focused on me
that's what kid that [ __ ] counts okay
you add it all up I don't think the
earth would have existed this long if if
there weren't a ton of people out there
who wanted you know humanity to be alive
and wanting us to exist and want us to
experience you know even just had a
little drive inside of us as people I
think that all accumulates out there but
I I appreciate you for having some
strength there to share you share your
words there Julio you know I feel you
know when you said that you lost your
brother made me just feel grateful I
have had my brother you know I spoke to
my brother this morning and and for
years man I didn't have him you know I
he was out there and and we didn't have
any sense of family growing up man our
all our family did was fight you know I
didn't love my brothers and sisters do
it honestly you know it hurts me to say
that but I didn't care I didn't give a
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] about them
I don't even [ __ ] about me but then this
morning you know like you know I just
get to talk to my brother and we just
you know even fisted for like a minute
in the world we get to be brothers you
know on the phone
and it's just like I could its I could
tell them a million times I'm happier my
brother can tell you could tell me that
but that there's nothing it doesn't
whatever we say doesn't have anything on
whatever there is this weird little
magic that's in the air when we're able
to just be brothers you know and to know
that there's somebody out there as close
in format and template as me to me who's
also trying to survive and trying to
take care of themselves and so when
those people are struggling like your
brother was uh you know I know that pain
is uh probably really intense and uh an
appreciation and sharing that thought
with us today is sharing your experience
and your hope and your strength and
stuff with what they young fell out
there and learning it and anybody
anywhere and this showing about getting
off drugs this show isn't about all of
that [ __ ] if you fall if you ballin out
there if you got a eight ball and you
just bought a [ __ ] swing set you know
what I'm saying
Gang Gang Boy enter the Paralympics I
don't give a [ __ ] you know I'm saying if
you can do cocaine and [ __ ] cook hot
dogs with your friends do that [ __ ]
enjoy yourself you know I'm saying if
you drink are you free
you know you freebasing out there but
you still you know clocking in to work
and feeding your kids then go on this
isn't about any of that boy you don't
saying as soon as they come out a little
bit of a safer LSD you know I'll be out
there you know I'll be hiding little uh
them little bitty square post-it notes
under my tongue Gang Gang boy I'll take
LSD in that eyedropper boy what do you
see in the future so this isn't about
that it's in that show but this is a
show where if somebody [ __ ] calls it
and they're struggling dude we'll be
there you know saying this like if
somebody's calling in there turning up
you know I'm saying if you knuckle deep
if you're freaking six feet deep in the
graveyard and a mushroom jacket and your
brain starts taking that scavenger hunt
on that dope gang gang will be right
there hit that hotline get greasy boy
get greasy and share that trip with us
we're not looking down on anything like
that we're not looking down or anything
like that man
buddies welcome here you know I'm saying
if they tell you if people and if
somebody in your life has ever told you
you told you you aren't welcome then you
are definitely double welcome here you
know if somebody's ever told you that
you know because of you you know that
your people or the you know you that
your people aren't good people or you're
you know just because of where you're
from you don't deserve it you don't you
know people look at you sideways cuz you
from the poorest out of town man [ __ ]
them you know [ __ ] them because you know
what one day we'll see them on the other
side of town dude you know saying well
we weren't wheat when we neighbors oh
now now who's a neighbor and now you
normally cook the liver and onions on
the stove and since we share an
air-conditioned events in this fancy
townhouse condominium complex I'm gonna
blow this i'ma blow this most nasty
cooking smells ever into your house
liver and onions boy duck duck vaginas
I'm gonna grill up a pan full of duck
vaginas and let that and let that smoke
smog smell seeped through the air vents
into your house and now you come looking
at me sideways
you know and you don't know anything
about them duck VG's cuz you never had
to eat all that you never been out there
you know saying you never had you never
you never been out there having eat
chicken fillets whatever the [ __ ] that
is you know you never been out there
eating pigeon boy salmon fronts I've had
salmon fronts brah and that's just head
and skin daddy gang
ah so that man look man I've had fun man
I've had fun I had fun I'm glad that I
came in here today I'm glad that you
guys have been so supportive and I'm
glad look man if you want to check out
you know some of your favorite
celebrities I gotta I gotta get this a
head in there right now you got to go to
star flow man start flowing a joke dude
you know in it when everybody's stealing
everybody's like information right now
star flows out they're keeping your
stuff safe star flow is reshaping the
influencer economy by providing a
network enabling an ecosystem where
individuals can thrive and where
everybody can interact and participate
in the creation and consumption of value
if you're a fan if you're a creator if
you are if you're an advertiser if
you're a brand you can all meet in this
place star flow calm check out the app
and this but this isn't a place where
people are stealing your information
this is a place where we are keeping
things clean so you like Muhammad Ali
you know I'm saying you like Abraham
Lincoln you like listening to you know
Abraham Lincoln bootlegs and [ __ ]
or maybe some videos he might have left
go find your favorite celebrity star Flo
comm check out the app just go see what
it's like to be in a safe environment on
the Internet
not out here where if you google you
know you know you looking for a pair of
shoes next thing you know you walk
outside and there are three models
walking by in those pairs of shoes
because that's the dark arts of
advertising and that's what they're
doing they advertise them to you it's
all advertising boy [ __ ] men make
your own moccasins and check out star
flow calm or the app star flow oh man
man I appreciate you guys being here you
know I don't have to do a comedy sets
and I did I feel good about it honestly
you know I feel good I want to catch up
on that Joe Rogan episode with Owen
Benjamin and uh Kurt Metzger Kurt is so
crazy if you get to go watch that Kurt
is such a I just love watching Kurt he's
so funny to watch happy birthday to
Fahim Anwar he's a young comedian and
his birthday uh and it's his birthday so
check that out
if you get a chance go check out his
stuff man you guys got me filled up with
gratitude you know you guys got me
filled up with gratitude you know I went
to a meeting this morning and it just
just remember you know just if I go into
a meeting in the morning sometimes it
sets my it sets me for the day a little
bit more comfortably you know and I'm
happy to be alive for another week and
be able to you know at least be able to
embrace what's going on around me and to
show up and and be able to spend time
with you guys here this was fun we had
some fun stuff we talked about some fun
stuff you know I'll make sure to reach
out to the London gent with with some of
the information that you guys had we had
some other callers for people that are
entering talking about their weekend
we'll hit those on Monday but um we're
gonna leave you out here with a little
bit of Koli Garrett and and I'm gonna
leave you out just just saying thank you
you know you guys inspired me some
people inspire me to spy people giving
an F you know I talked to a buddy of
mine a buddy of mine ed he lives down in
North Carolina and I met him we met at a
comedy show I guess I don't know and
we've become buddies and you know and he
uh and I was talking to him he sent me a
text yesterday he said man you know when
that kid that London kid called it got
me geeked out I was geeking up and uh
and then the emails and everything it
just made me feel you know it made me
feel made me feel that's what it did
boom
made me feel um wow so I want to think
oh I wanted to say oh I got some candles
man I'm gonna unbox them right now hold
on one second let me grab them
I know what these are they have this
company this and they don't work you
know the same there's just a gift from
my boy J Piemonte Piemonte Tay and we'll
put it a candle linked to their company
this was just a gift that he sent this
wasn't he asked me to advertise or
anything but I know people like to see
some unboxing and stuff videos so it's a
crack and it is second damn [ __ ]
light fixtures dude we got right here
boy and what we talking about candles
earlier
oh [ __ ] you put all this paper in here
these little bitty pieces of paper
shredded paper man we just got the
studio jack I can't even open this man
not here anyway we have to open this
outsider and you know in a poor person's
front yard where they don't care if you
just leave a bunch of [ __ ] out there boy
did I remember when I was growing up
they somebody around I had a
veterinarian I guess used to throw dead
animals in our ditch man we had I never
I never wanted it and really know
nothing about animals you know but the
problem was all the but I knew a bone
structure man dude I knew it damn I mean
I could uh you know I could I could show
you if I could point out a pelvis of a
yellow retrieve from probably about 40
feet away and it's just those the things
you learn man where I'm from you notice
that the things you learn I'm her first
time I ever even got into my
neighborhood dude this old man he died
in a ditch fire you know he almost he
came out of it the first time flaming
boy throwing punches he was still
fighting this dude was probably 86 years
old and he was fighting this other fat
guy that didn't huh didn't own a shirt
you know and I only think this dude was
Irish but he said he was kind of Irish
but um but he didn't own a shirt and he
only spoke in vowels and this dude they
were fighting and this he threw that man
in a ditch fire and that do came back at
him boy swinging with them flaming
flaming fist and then the dude threw him
then they threw him back in but yeah so
that's why I'm from boy no I'm saying
I'm out here you're out here
we got the got new dates coming up dark
art store I'll tell you more about it on
Monday you guys be good yourselves
you probably deserve it let's leave out
of here with again with my boy
coley Garrett Daisy I've been thinking
and you know thinking it is a sin if
they ask you
where you go
just tell them where
you've been
[Music]
Monday
a third Friday I shelving days his wife
must be
[ __ ] rusty
my boys please agents are misery
[Music]
days
we can
but always
Smith through
Daisy
Mountain
I mean never
do the best you can you know don't be
too hard on yourselves do the best you
can
that's what we trying to do my I want to
thank Chris Perez you know this young
gentleman man is beautiful Latino he's
probably a hundred or maybe even 70
percent Latino I don't even know no
Bruce he's gonna come in he's gonna edit
this my boy Chris Perez is gonna come in
and night and edit this hitter so I'm
grateful for that you know he's been
helping produce this thing I'm boy Nick
Davis out there you know came over part
of her oldest camp and he came over
where he's helping out my boy Ryan sure
man I did I'll send this [ __ ] out forget
finished sometimes 1:00 a.m. and I'm the
ID how need help edit an audio and I'll
get that text from him hey man you need
some help
I'm up man could not be more thankful
well I'll play it for you one more time
on the way out this is ode to Daisy by
Coley gujrat and I'll see you guys on
Monday if you need something hit the
hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three as always look you
know I don't have any medical training I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about
so uh please take that into account
y'all be good
Daisy I've been thinking and you know
thinking it is it's seen if they ask you
where you going
just tell them where it is you've been
Monday through Friday ourselves and
Aizaz one must be
slit rusty my mornings from his agents
are misery
[Music]
we can but always his in Smith through
Daisy
Mountain I mean never
I may never get over maybe
damn useless just like going
Pepa
oh you take no prisoners you know I
really wouldn't
[Music]
- ugh
that season
not true but I did go that I take
[Music]